hi there steve kaufman here and uh
today i want to talk about
how to study effectively not just how to
learn languages but how to study
effectively remember if you enjoy these
videos please subscribe
click on the bell to get notifications
uh i'd like to do actually a series of
four videos
uh i'd like to talk about
how to study effectively based on my
experience in learning languages what
i've read about learning languages what
i've read about how the brain works what
i remember from when i was at school
some of the things that
i think language instruction does
that
is not successful in schools
and why the same unsuccessful method is
used to teach other subjects causing a
lot of frustration for people so first
of all today i'm simply going to talk
about
how to study effectively in general
and then in the second in this series i
hope to do a series of four actually in
the second series i'll talk about
why i think language instruction in
schools is not effective
then in the third in this series i want
to talk about
you know
learning in a month or you know uh how
to learn quickly and and all of the
different hints and tips and and hacks
that are offered on the internet for how
to learn languages quickly my views on
these and and again tying it all back to
studying effectively in general
and then in the final one
i'm going to talk about learning a
language from scratch so how again
applying the sort of principles of
effective study
to
uh you know learning a language from
scratch
so um i'm not going to talk about
specifically language learning or about
link people complain that i mentioned
link although i love link and that's
where i learn languages
and what we do at link in a sense is a
reflection
of
my view of how we learn
but i'm going to talk about learning
and study effective study generally all
right
first of all the first thing i think we
need to do
to study effectively is to improve our
reading skills if we aren't good readers
we need to become good readers to read
faster to get better at acquiring
information through reading because
reading is very effective very efficient
it enables us to access so much
information whether in you know a paper
type of book a traditional book or an
e-book where we can you know look things
up if we're on a
ipad or on a computer
being careful to be you know to avoid
distractions granted
so reading is super powerful
uh also get used to listening
uh
again listening is something that we can
do wherever we are
we can enjoy the voice of the person
explaining i find you reading and
listening more
effective than video because with video
we are captive
video can be part of a study plan
it can be fun to watch video
it's sometimes possible to explain
things
via video
in a way that we can't in a book
so i think you need a combination of all
three so let me talk about combining
reading
listening and video
we're talking about combining and i
think combining is a big part of
learning
i found that in learning languages but
not only in learning languages in
learning other subjects i had to sort of
get at the whatever i was trying to
learn
using different
approaches different books different
resources don't just try to
memorize the textbook you you have to
try and force yourself to go out and
find other resources that cover the same
material
and that's why we combine video with
listening with audio with with reading
because
the brain the way the brain works is the
brain is not very good at sort of
acing something now
learning some specific
bits of knowledge or facts or even a
you know some
mathematical equation
these are things that we kind of learn
them and there's it's difficult for the
brain you know again i'm not a
neuroscientist but they go into the
hippocampus and they don't stay there
very long but the strength of the brain
is its ability to sort of start to
identify patterns and that's why we have
to be patient
and keep feeding the brain
you know the same kind you know i refer
to it as grazing and interleaving some
of the same material interspersed with
going off and doing something else and
then coming back and reading about this
or
in some other format so that this
combination learning grazing learning
is according to research much more
effective than trying to nail something
down
and
that's why it's it's so
counterproductive
in the school system where they teach
you something and now because they've
taught it to you therefore they think
you should be able to
you know reproduce it or be tested on it
and of course you can't so you only get
six out of ten which is frustrating
as a learner we have to remember that
however difficult something may seem
uh whether it be a language or a concept
in mathematics or in science or anything
else
in time the brain will develop a pattern
that enables us to grasp the concept
better and better slowly the emphasis is
on slowly and manfred spitzer whom i
always quote he says you know the brain
can't do otherwise than learn the brain
will gradually learn create patterns to
deal with all the stimulus and and and
information that's coming at it it'll
drop some of the details but it'll start
forming a pattern and when you have this
pattern in your brain it becomes easier
than to remember some of the details
because you have a context the brain has
created this this uh
network of
patterns that makes it then easier to
learn so it's very important not to be
frustrated if we read this explanation
five times and it still doesn't make
sense or we keep forgetting things
and of course we get six out of ten or
three out of ten on the test
and we shouldn't allow ourselves to be
discouraged of course the education
system is set up that way it's set up
that way because for whatever reason
the people in charge of education feel
that they have to test you at every step
of the way to make sure you're learning
something
in reality
what was taught yesterday may not click
in for another six months so it's kind
of meaningless to test us immediately on
on what's in our short-term memory for
example
rather
we should you know as teachers encourage
learners to cover the same ground
using different material and we as
learners should resist
this sort of sense of frustration that
we can't understand that we can't
remember it we can't do it it doesn't
make sense we have to continue
and and that's again always i go back to
this idea of combining things watch a
video by all means but then also if you
can find and and in the case of science
and math you have can academy which is
tremendous but you should just still at
the same time work on your reading work
on reading explanations of the same
thing again without that sense of
you know frustration or fear as you're
not still not able to remember or grasp
it all just keep going it's slowly going
to sock into place just the way
languages slowly suck into place
and
you know work on all the different
aspects of your brain including the
emotional side of your brain so if you
can listen to something that's pleasant
where you enjoy the voice if you don't
like
listening to your professor but if you
can find some other audio which is more
interesting or where you enjoy the voice
listen to that but you still have to go
back and and read or listen to what the
professor had to say because you gotta
you gotta you know
write the exam and most professors like
to have
things come back to them the way they
they uh you know taught it
but so so as
as a general principle in in learning i
think all of the things that i say about
language learning when i think back you
know when i did well in a subject it's
because i got interested in the subject
i read up on it using different
resources
and and so and the other thing too is as
with language learning
uh of course it's good to talk and
exchange views about a subject that
you're learning and to talk to the other
people in the class and to talk to the
teacher and so forth but
you have to have something in you before
you can talk about the subject just as
with language learning you can't begin
by speaking you have to begin by
allowing your brain to get used to it
and that's where the reading and the
listening primarily and to some extent a
video
is kind of the prerequisite and once
you've got some of those patterns in
your brain then yeah the more you can
talk about it and do experiments and do
things and and activate some of these
things that you have brought into your
brain the better you're going to do so
that's sort of a general discussion on
how to study effectively
the big message is to my mind is don't
allow yourself to get frustrated
get hung up at your mistakes or perhaps
your your results on a test or things
that you forget
try to find a way to get interested in
in the subject
and that may mean that your textbook is
boring find some other material and
graze around and cover the same ground
in different ways and i think that's an
effective way to study